apparently there's like a third Jewish
participant with like fairy Porsche and
there was like a third partner so it's
three of them and they used to have like
a racing team so they used to kind of
like build cars together maybe they
didn't know they just heard Supreme race
and they're like let's get in it yeah
[Music]
like how do we win and they're like you
already are is that factually accurate
we have a Jew here well the Jew is a
great first name Adolf Rosenberger
provided the financial backing obviously
Porsche proportion for Porsche yeah but
Porsche is a Jewish car brand you could
potentially say that's what I'm [__]
talking about because I'm not supporting
the Nazis I'm supporting the Jews by
buying my fake Porsche [__] you got that
Jewish ass nose otherwise but not this
is aerodynamic just knows like Aryan
Dynamics